other than the co-main event
outside of Steamroller and Drew Dober is
my favorite matchup on the card uh our
boy Bilal Mohammed versus Gilbert Burns
uh both food truck alumni I hate picking
against either one of these guys but
um Muhammad's a plus 110. I like the
dogs here listen when this fight got
announced shortly like a week ago uh you
know Muhammad coming off
um you know his fight over Sean Brady
the the hardcore fan base wants to him
get a title shot this is a whoever wins
this guaranteed gets a title shot now
you're not gonna fight next and I talked
to Muhammad about that you have to wait
which is worth it you know he's been
doing it long enough but this is gonna
be a title Contender fight so whoever
wins I would almost guarantee gets a
title shot next after Colby and Leon
fight